because I I couldn't help but think
about he who remains warning about the
variants and yeah you know King has got
to be one of those ones that he was
talking about when you're approaching
all these variants do you approach them
as completely separate characters or is
that like a thread for you that connects
them uh I guess both you know
um
I guess both but I have to break it down
you know and make it they're all
I think of almost all different movies
all different characters all different
circumstances and I think that's what
helps me I have to do that in order to
really diversify them you know and keep
them as far away from each other as
possible uh uh that's just my artistic
ego where like I don't want them to be
similar that's the job you know
um and yet there is something
uh there's a germ you know there's a
there's something in the DNA of a Kang
and and their respective variants you
know there's something in there and that
is the thing that I kind of can go keep
to myself you know not even uh it's not
even a declaration from from from the
MCU world it's just something for me in
my process that I've got to keep that
that oyster shut you know because that
little Kang thing that I'm working with
uh seems be working but just just gotta
keep it moving you know
yeah you know one of the many things I
was impressed with in this movie was
even just the look of King that full
costume like it's really got that curvy
Vibe even the way that the light
reflects off it what was it like for you
looking at yourself for the first time
in that outfit I'm glad you brought that
up because that's one of those moments
you know like we're young we're young
men We're Young fellas yet you know and
you but we understand the world and we
understand this is going to be the first
time
you know and sometimes you gotta take it
as fast as things are moving sometimes
you take a step back and that was so uh
up such a moment when I saw it there
and we had done all the fittings and
okay now it's it's gonna fit put it on
and once you put it on it's it's the
beginning you know this is the beginning
you know
um and so yeah it had that sense of
occasion when I put it on I felt the
responsibility I felt the fun and it you
know uh
yeah it was and then after that I
cranked the music up we went to camera
test and he was photographed for the
first time it was uh it was Monumental I
think for me for me yeah that's awesome
Paul was telling me about the fight
scene that you guys filmed and it took a
couple weeks to do uh can you compare
what it's like going up against Paul
Rudd versus was going up against uh
Michael B Jordan
yes like uh
it's kind of apples and oranges you know
different weight class you know anyone
who fights understands that you know you
can only your opponent is uh is what is
is telling you what to throw when to
throw it you know and so they're both
very different uh Warriors you know uh
and the circumstances were very
different you know
um but yeah they're both I'll say this
uh I probably took harder punches from
uh
uh Michael no I probably took harder
punches from Paul Rudd uh okay and
probably gave harder punches to Michael
B
okay right on but that's because I had
the glove on
yeah yeah
oh man I gotta say congratulations once
again I'm I'm very excited for what
comes next for you and all these all
these Kings uh thanks for that time man
yeah be good bro appreciate it cheers
peace